you just saw with Sara that when you
work on a project you'll often have
multiple files that you want to track
together get calls such a collection of
files a repository when you save a
version of your files in git in other
words when you make a commit you will
save a version of every file in your
repository if you only have one file in
your repository for example game is you
already know that get stores a version
of your file each time you choose to
commit so if you committed changes at
one o'clock 215 609 654 and 820 then it
would look like this but you might also
have some other files in your repository
for example index.html and index dot CSS
you don't need to understand what these
files are the important thing is that
all three files are connected so they're
all required for the game to function
properly
git will also track the state of these
files each time you commit a commit is a
snapshot of every file in your
repository at the time you choose to
make the commit so for example this is
the fourth commit in this repository if
you've only changed game j/s in this
fourth commit then index dot HTML and
index dot CSS will be identical between
these two commits on the other hand you
can change all the files in a single
commit for example if you added a new
button in the third commit that would
affect all three files so if you did a
diff between the second and the third
commit you would see the differences in
all three let's take a look at how that
looks first I'll do a git log and I'll
use the - - that option which gives some
statistics about which files have
changed in each commit so we can see all
the same information here as before but
each commit also shows which files were
affected in that commit you can see that
these most recent two commits only
affected game Jas the green plus signs
indicate additions and the red minus
signs indicate deletions so you can see
that in this commit some code was added
and some code was deleted the number of
pluses and minuses is proportional to
the size of the change you don't need to
worry about the unit's but you can see
that this second commit is a much bigger
total change than the first commit now
I'll scroll down a bit to try to find a
commit that affects more than one file
here's one you can see that this come
affected game.js index.html and iPad
Gaius now I'll press Q to stop viewing
the get log output and I'll go ahead and
type git diff and the to commit IDs that
I want to compare so this one and this
one like before we see output indicating
which file has been changed first game
is changed and here's the diff for game
Jas next we see that index.html was
changed and scrolling down we can also
see the differ in Dex HTML finally iPad
jeaious was also changed and we can
scroll down to see the changes to that
file